eine Parkgarage in Taipei ein
Schlachtfeld an diesem Sonntagvormittag
20 Männer Lehrer Banker Studenten
allesamt schwer bewaffnet spielen Krieg
doch die Grenzen verschwimmen in den
Köpfen unter den Helmen Spiel trifft es
nicht so ganz sie nehmen es sehr ernst
ich sehe das als reales Kriegsszenario
so gehe ich daran an oberster Stelle
steht dass ich überlebe und meine
Kameraden sichere
Charles 38 Ingenieur von Beruf hat viel
investiert sie alle haben das nur die
Waffen sind nicht echt wobei die Airsoft
Gewehre optisch keinen Unterschied
erkennen lassen ansonsten könnten sie
mit ihrer Ausrüstung auch in einen
richtigen Einsatz ziehen das ist die
Idee und Charles Bär bereit
ich war schon als Schüler sehr am
Militär interessiert und als dann in den
vergangenen Monaten die Bedrohung durch
China immer größer wurde habe ich mit
diesem Sport angefangen weil ich dachte
ich muss mich vorbereiten wenn wir einen
möglichen Angriffs überstehen wollen
können hier alle unter seinem Kampfnamen
Mister Bär wenn er spricht hören die
anderen zu seine Tipps sind willkommen
er ist erfahren Kampf erprobt Mister Bär
war 15 Jahre Soldat einer taiwanischen
Eliteeinheit
immer mehr Leute interessieren sich für
unsere Aktivitäten früher war das nur
ein Spiel dass die Jungs vielleicht zwei
Jahre gespielt haben dann haben sie
geheiratet und dann war es vorbei aber
jetzt motiviert sie Taiwans
geopolitische Lage und unsere Ausrüstung
wird auch immer besser realistischer
jetzt bleiben die Leute wesentlich
länger dabei
die Ballerei in der Parkgarage unten ist
für Fortgeschrittene fünf Etagen höher
in Mr bears Trainingszentrum geht's
dagegen erstmal um die Grundlagen
viele haben heute zum ersten Mal eine
Waffe in der Hand sei es auch nur ein
Airsoft Gewehr und auch sonst noch nicht
viel Ahnung
auf den ersten Blick sehen die Uniformen
sehr ähnlich aus aber unsere Leute
müssen sie unterscheiden lernen was
trägt der Feind für eine Uniform auf dem
Schlachtfeld könntest du sonst Freund
und Feind nicht auseinanderhalten aber
das ist natürlich wichtig wenn die
Soldaten der chinesischen Armee kommen
ganz unterschiedliche Leute haben sich
zum Kurs angemeldet
auffallend jung die meisten
ein paar Freaks mögen darunter sein
militär-fans und emsige computer-shooter
aber es kommen auch welche die bisher
nichts mit kämpfen oder Schießen zu tun
hatten nun aber meinen es müsste sein
ich glaube an die Stärke unserer Armee
und zähle auch auf die Unterstützung
unserer Alliierten
aber trotzdem jeder von uns sollte schon
wissen wie er sich im Krieg verteidigt
wenn es dann wirklich losgeht
Waffenkunde die Airsoft Gewehre
verschießen Kunststoffkugeln aber
Spielzeug kann man das wohl nicht mehr
nennen Design Gewicht Handling alles ist
ganz nah am Original
die Arme ausgestreckt die Hände ruhig
Savannah lernt beängstigend
der Gedanke dass ich im richtigen Leben
eine Waffe einsetzen könnte fühlt sich
unwirklich an aber können sie sich denn
vorstellen mit einer echten Waffe auf
einen Menschen zu schießen
wenn ich müsste dann würde ich es tun
wenn ich müsste ja
der Ernstfall wie nah sind Sie dran sehr
nah sagt Mr Bea
China droht immer wieder es werde Taiwan
angreifen wenn wir uns nicht beugen und
uns China anschließen dann wenden Sie
Gewalt an
das jüngste Beispiel lässt doch die
Ukraine die Leute haben den Feind nicht
ernst genommen sie haben nicht geglaubt
dass ein Krieg kommt aber dann ist es
doch passiert
für das Airsoft Probetraining ist Taiwan
bestens gerüstet zeigt sich in der
Fabrik im zweiten Stock des Hauses 70%
aller Druckluftwaffen werden im Land
hergestellt in die Welt exportiert aber
zuletzt hat gerade die heimische
Nachfrage angezogen Waffengesetze in
Taiwan sind streng der Besitz echter
Waffen verboten umso wichtiger da sind
sich Mister Bär und Fabrikbesitzer
Ernesto einig ist die Chance mit Airsoft
zu trainieren
wir haben in Taiwan eine leistungsfähige
Industrie für Airsoftwaffen die sollten
wir nutzen es gibt natürlich ein paar
Unterschiede zu echten Waffen in der
Dynamik beim Rückschlag aber ansonsten
ist das sehr nah dran wenn jemand mit
der Airsoftwaffe umgehen kann fällt der
Umstieg auf echte Waffen leicht das
erhöht die Verteidigungsfähigkeit
dauernd
kaum eine Waffe auf der Welt die Ernesto
nicht nachbauen könnte die Lizenzen
dafür hat er sich von den
Originalherstellern gesichert
das ist die amerikanische m4-serie sehr
beliebtes Modell verkaufen wir ganz oft
die Ähnlichkeit zum Original ist sehr
groß und im Prinzip ist auch die
Handhabe gut vergleichbar mit der echten
Waffe
Taiwans Armee nutzt das t-71 Gewehr
Magazinwechsel Grifftechnik Nachladen
das ist ganz ähnlich wie beim
amerikanischen M4 also wer mit diesem M4
Airsoft Modell zurechtkommt kann leicht
auf das echte taiwanische T71 umsteigen
auch die Fabrik so sieht es jedenfalls
ihr Besitzer könnte im Kriegsfall
durchaus ihren Beitrag leisten dann
würde aus dem Spaß endgültig Ernst
die Produktion unserer Airsoftwaffen ist
im Grunde anspruchsvoller als die echter
Waffen Antrieb Aufbau und Struktur ist
hier komplizierter wenn wir eines Tages
auf die Produktion echter Waffen
umstellen müssten dann ginge das ganz
schnell und einfach
der große Nachbar China droht und diese
Taiwaner nehmen das sehr ernst für sie
liegt Spiel und Krieg nah beieinander
Krieg und Frieden auch
[Musik]